hey youtubers is Charlie so Avengers
infinity war is coming up Marvel's never
been doing better but Marvel fans are
more pissed than ever so I'm going to
explain what's going on as we head into
infinity war the last couple years does
weird things been happening at Marvel
where their comics have been doing
steadily worse and worse but their
movies have been doing better and better
they've been making more money they've
been doing well with the critics which
is almost unheard of but this past year
they almost hit rock bottom but they
will be saved by Avengers infinity war
I'll explain how that's going to work
there is a new round of the spider-man
giveaway - it's a $20 comixology gift
card all you have to do to enter is be a
subscriber and leave a comment on this
video
so right now Marvel is blowing it up but
when most people think about Marvel they
think about the movies they don't think
about the comics as much even though
there are hundreds and hundreds of
stories from all the characters
published each year you have to consider
though the total comic book sales for
all publishers combined worldwide last
year with somewhere like a close a
billion dollars in Marvel does that with
just one of its movies so the movies are
a multi billion dollar industry there
are comics you have to consider that
they're like a percentage of total comic
book sales or in the hundreds of million
so it's a fraction of that so a lot of
people don't always pay attention when
really big stuff is happening in the
comics even though there is a really big
thing getting ready to happen the next
big arc for Marvel comics is called
Captain America secret Empire and he
seems like he's going to be the central
focus of their big comic book event
later this year that'll spill into next
year so remember next year is infinity
war so it's going to be an Avengers year
they'll have already had their first big
spider-man movie and typically the
comics follow the movies now used to be
the other way around like the reason
they did civil war - like the reason
they called it that was because they had
Captain America Civil War coming out
even though in the Civil War title there
was very little actual civil war going
on not the best big comic book event
that marvelous at DC rebirth' did way
better and that gets into why people are
super upset because Marvel Comics right
now unlike
movies are tanking they're comic sales
are a fraction of DC sales for the last
several years they have been pounding DC
and sales but this past year they had
this big diversity push they had all-new
all-different now they got rid of
Ironman they got rid of the Hulk they
replaced them with other characters in
their titles in their sales are tanking
people are pissed so if you don't read
comics and you don't know what's going
on
they had their Civil War two event at
the end of that they didn't quite kill
off Tony Stark but they effectively
killed him off in another character
called riri Williams took over his
invincible Iron Man comic with the name
iron heart so she's wearing the armor
her AI is actually made of Tony Stark's
consciousness so he's still around but
he's not iron man anymore dr. doom stole
his armor and stole the title so
remember I said the comics follow the
movies now
well Sony has a big Spider Man movie
coming out what a coincidence that Peter
Parker is the only character left on top
he's actually doing pretty well in the
Marvel Comics right now he's sort of
like the benefactor the Tony Stark of
the Avengers he's the one with all the
money because he has this big
billion-dollar corporation he has his
own version of the Avengers tower so
he's kind of like the Tony Stark of the
Marvel Universe right now but he is the
only one everybody else is like a
slightly different version of their
character there's the female Thor is the
Amadeus Cho version of the Hulk and even
though they're doing a lot of really
interesting things most comic book fans
after like the first couple issues got
really pissed and like okay we want the
characters that we love to come back so
Marvel because their sales are doing so
poorly we'll probably do their own
version of DC rebirth in another year or
two if they don't do it by infinity war
it will happen the year after that just
because they have this big Captain
America event that's coming up so
they'll probably do that and then decide
whether or not to just completely reboot
everything the way that DC did this past
year I did a couple videos about it but
what happened is is DC sales had gotten
so bad the Geoff Johns and the other
powers that be just decided to do a
complete reboot where they brought back
all the changes that they had made
a couple years ago with the new 52 so
people were pissed during the new 52
there were a couple characters that
maybe you liked maybe you liked those
comics but overall sales started to
plummet because all the characters that
people loved had gone away they
completely rewritten all this continuity
so what they did is they press the hard
reset eject button and we got DC rebirth
it was amazing everybody loved it and it
is selling like gangbusters they're
outselling Marvel by a crazy amount way
more than you would ever think possible
so it's a very clear indicator that
people are not happy with what Marvel is
doing right now and they're really happy
the DC brought back all this old stuff
so you can do the math even though the
people at Marvel and people at DC get
along really really well they look at
what each other's doing all the time so
mark my words sales continue to plummet
Marvel will do their own version of DC
Reapers now they totally call it
something different they're not going to
call it Marvel rebirth but because
infinity war is happening next year they
will probably target that for some big
event and they'll use that as a way to
reboot all their characters without
completely destroying everything that
everyone's loved for so long so if
you've been reading comics for a long
time this is nothing new to you there's
always like a stretch of comics for some
big story arc that just doesn't pay off
Marvel and DC will always double down
and come back with something that's even
better but the problem is is that it
takes a long time to publish a comic and
it takes a long time to make a movie so
if there's like a movie that Marvel has
in the future that doesn't do really
well it'll take them a little while to
come back with something even better but
I think the best example of that are the
soar movies as a franchise Thor has done
really well at the box-office critically
not so much if you go back after
watching Captain America Civil War and
try to watch the first door film or even
the second door film you'll just shake
your head and wonder what's going on
even watching the first Avengers film
almost feels like you're watching a long
episode of TV because of the way they
filmed it so a lot of those early
problems that Marvel had they slowly
ironed out technical issues the way they
film things looks better now but Thor
Ragnarok just because it takes so
long to make these sequels is going to
be one of the best weirdest films ever
in the weird part is the reason why it's
going to be so cool so you have all
these great actors but the problem is is
that when Marvel was first getting
started with its movies it was such a
big financial risk that they tried to
make the most least objectionable movies
possible like they just sanded all the
edges off all the interesting stuff down
so that nobody would be upset they
wouldn't offend anyone nothing would be
weird but then Kevin Feige was able to
sort of like break off and do his own
thing
and now they are free to be as weird as
they want they've earned that trust from
the fans so it took a while to get there
but you look at movies like Doctor
Strange and like ant-man totally weird
compared to the straight-up Avengers
film but did really well financially for
the type of movies that they were you
know very small in comparison so that is
why I'm so excited about what's going on
with Marvel movies just the fact that
they're embracing that weirdness but
staying true to the characters and that
is the same reason that the comics are
tanking right now is because comic book
fans feel like they're not being true to
those characters like you have an Iron
Man comic book with no Iron Man in it
why would you want to read that you know
a lot of the comic book sales now are
driven by movie watchers that want to
read adventures with those characters
but you can't do that with any of
Marvel's comics right now all of the
straight-up heroes that you see in the
movies are off doing other things or
they're dead Kevin Feige and all the
directors producers actors have teased
that infinity war in the movies is going
to be the culmination of all the types
of things that they've been doing since
phase 1 going forward after that
everything is going to be very different
even though they'll still be very true
to the characters now what does that
mean so we haven't seen Thor Ragnarok
yet but they're talking about more buddy
roadtrip type movies where you have
team-up like you have Iron Man in a
spider-man movie there'll be a lot more
crossovers more small weird movies so
like the next time you see a Captain
America movie you might see him with
black panther like they might do that
instead of doing another Captain America
sequel now that doesn't mean that
they're not going to do sequels anymore
but they're just going to do a lot more
mixing and matching with characters
infinity war is really that point of
transition so that is probably when
they'll target for their marvel comic's
rebirth
where they bring everybody back in new
interesting ways but they do it in a way
that's true to those comic-book
characters so you guys can let me know
what do you think about Marvel Comics in
this past year most people have been
complaining like most people just are
really unsatisfied but how long do you
think it's going to be before they roll
back all these changes you have to
imagine that the same thing was kind of
happening at DC films like they're
slowly working the kinks out so it's
like okay we have some really awesome
things here but the characters aren't
exactly the way we want them to be so
we'll fix this a little bit going
forward everybody will be happy it'll be
wonderful but publishing comics making
movies it just takes a lot of time so
even though they might already be making
those changes
they definitely already made those
changes at DC films but Marvel Comics
you might not see that pay off till
later this year or even next year so if
you're a hardcore comic book fan you
know that you should just stick it out
it'll all be fine in the end but it just
might take a little while to get there
there was some new spider-man and
legends footage to just drop so I'll
probably do videos for that next I have
some Game of Thrones I want to post and
they've been talking about Green Lantern
so I'll try to get that stuff out as
fast as possible there's a whole bunch
of really cool comic book news that just
dropped well you just wait so that's a
post you can click here to learn all
about Superman black costume hype and
you can click here to learn all about
the future of x-23 in the wolverine
character inside the x-men universe
thank you so much for watching everybody
let's high five I'll see you guys
tonight